non riesco a comprendere perché dobbiamo
sempre passare per cretini in tutti i
film strill mi fa davvero impazzire se
ci penso mi rende insana mentalmente mi
fa venire voglia di malmenare infanti al
mio signore gesù capisci cosa intendo e
tipo oh gesù e tipo assurdo è
completamente tipo un'esplosione da
nazione al mondo a visitarti ascoltare
[Applauso]
pechino 6 sala insomma ciao a tutti ora
questa breve intro porta dritto dritto
al nocciolo della questione perché non
spara ormai siti nei quali è pronto a
scannarsi come un tacchino grasso dopo
40 giorni di digiuno quaresimale e tu
piangi piangi cioè non è possibile tutto
ciò voglia dire chi di noi non
sparerebbe non è proprio una cosa una
cosa reale voglio dire ste finalmente
davanti al killer psicopatico che per
tutto il film ha cercato di di
ammazzarti ha fatto la strage di tutti i
due parenti e non lo ammazzi ma camera e
proprio corretta nei confronti di noi
spettatori come cosa tu non l'hai fatto
alto durante il film che farmi prendere
colpi con quei bambini di colpi di scena
che mi trovo ovunque peggio della
cipolla la prova del cuoco che poi
quando li film per sbaglio marco
intenzionalmente parte
un colpo che finisce quasi sempre per
beccare la gamma del matto la critica
del villaggio se ne esce con la frase da
galline del pollaio e coccodè pensi che
sia morto e no chi non è morto non ti
serve essere dottor house per capirlo
prezzo di sì
brutta pigna del cavolo ha beccato una
gamba non il cuore il cervello la gamba
dell'assassino ma non la vedi il fatto
che di colpo rimanga per terraferma non
vuol dire niente non voglio credere che
la tattica del se non ti muovi non ti
vede che con il tyrannosaurus rex
funzionava surgelati cpal possa
funzionare anche dei film non è reale e
questo è no tranquilli come se fosse
appena uscite dal negozio delle magie
delle braccia tranquilli lasciano la
pistola proprio avvicinata assassino
anzi in mano lasciargli hanno visto che
sei furbo se ne vanno dilata giusta se
il trucco a giocare a un due tre stella
poi tornano quello giustamente non c'è
più ed è pronto a core carle di botte in
quanto pagare per vedere una cosa
all'acs senza mazzi che lo so brutta un
nerd ass
pensi che sia morto cosa mi melani penso
che sia più che tra passato ed e solo a
quel punto ringrazierà in mezzo al
cinema con le lacrime agli occhi per la
gioia lanciando pop corn come se fosse
riso al matrimonio di mia cugina